stakes could not be higher
that is why the great taylor swift our
hero
is coming out to sing
our country back into a democrat malaise
why are so many powerful people trying
to make it so
difficult for us to vote it keeps the
look on your face the moment you heard
the news
you're screaming inside and frozen
inside
how quickly they forget
they aren't gonna help us too busy
helping themselves
[Music]
[Music]
oh
obviously none of that is true she opens
up with the kamala harris clip why are
so many people trying to make it so hard
to vote it has never been easier to vote
you don't need an id
you probably don't need to be an
american citizen you don't need to
request an absentee ballot you don't
need to show up on election day
you can vote basically whenever
apparently after the election perhaps
or at least after the deadline to send
in your
mail-in ballot it's never ever been
easier to it's much too easy to vote
right now
because the the system itself is open to
such fraud
and the men these men are just enriching
themselves they're enriching them
donald trump doesn't take a salary he's
lost a billion dollars in office
helping the country none of that is true
none of that is true i hope it's just
desperation
from our friends on the left i hope the
election goes well for us tonight
we will find out we're obviously going
to have that election coverage
in any case i would like to express a
little bit of gratitude for how fun
the past four years have been i hope it
continues for another four years i hope
we get another
a replay of election night 2016. so i
will say goodbye to you for now
until our election night later i hope
you enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you